does life imitate art or does art
imitate life
it's a question that has been asked
throughout human history this
philosophical debate is about the ways
art either reflects the world around us
or influences it but in the case of
scp-085
the idea of art imitating life takes on
a far
more literal meaning this entity was
created during an
experiment involving two separate scps
the first of these was scp-067
which is a fountain pen that when held
by a user will take full control of the
person's hand and
arm scp-067 then either writes about or
draws something linked to the user
holding it
the second of these scps was scp-942
better known as the clockworks this
massive piece of anomalous machinery
will have various effects depending on
what
or who is placed inside of it and which
of its several settings is chosen on the
selection panel
after test subject 1101f was given the
anomalous fountain pen
the result on the page was a simple
female figure
around 6 inches tall and 1.5 inches wide
she was drawn wearing a summer dress
with her long hair tied back in a
ponytail
and a single word was written underneath
her cassandra
as part of the experiment the drawing
was placed inside of scp-914
and the fine setting selected this is
the setting that is known to improve the
object placed inside of it in some way
for example a hunk of steel placed
inside will be transformed into a pile
of steel carpet tacks
a refined version of the steel when the
drawing was placed inside something
truly
amazing happened cassandra came to life
or as she now prefers to be called
cassie
scp-085 sometimes known as hand-drawn
cassie is a completely sentient being
she is fully able to communicate however
it all has to be done
non-verbally her voice cannot be heard
by anyone beyond the page where she was
drawn
but she is able to utilize sign language
or create writings on the page in order
to communicate with foundation
researchers scp-085 has been shown to
also be capable of understanding text
that is written on the same paper
she exists on she is fully animated
aware of her own existence and the
limitations of being two-dimensional
in nature according to profiling
conducted by the scp foundation
she has her own distinct personality
cassie is good-natured and
agreeable displaying a natural drive and
motivation
but also seems to feel the burden of
loneliness
living in solitude on the page it should
be noted that any and all attempts to
recreate the same experiment that formed
scp-085 had failed to create the same or
similar results tragically cassie might
be the only one
of her kind in existence a creation of
pure luck with no chance of making
another
no wonder she feels so lonely while
cassie is limited to her two-dimensional
form and has so far been unable to enter
our three-dimensional
world she has demonstrated several
different abilities on the page
firstly she is not solely confined to
the same paper she was drawn on
scp-085 is able to transfer herself from
sheet to sheet
if another page is placed flush with
hers she will be able to simply step
across
onto this new page however there is a
limit to what kind of page cassie is
able to transfer herself onto
she could easily take a stroll through
the pages of today's newspaper
but can't just wander onto someone's
family photos or anything made of
cardboard
glass or parchment for that matter
scp-085 can only exist on paper or
canvas and only when they are directly
connected to her original
page according to foundation testing
this is not exclusive to blank pieces of
paper either
if cassie ever transfers herself onto a
page bearing a repeated pattern
like a piece of wallpaper then she will
appear to be in the foreground while
everything else on the paper appears to
be behind her
scp-085 will perceive each page she
enters as a completely new place from
her point of view pattern pages seem to
be
like endless space additionally cassie
can also travel to other pieces of
artwork
and adopt the same art style of each new
environment she appears in
for example transferring herself onto
the pages of a comic book
will cause cassie to be rendered in an
artistic manner matching that of her
surroundings
the same occurs if she travels to an oil
painting watercolor or charcoal sketch
interestingly when appearing in comic
book form cassie's thoughts and speech
are visible through thought bubbles that
are commonly used to display text within
the comic medium
her size and the angle she is viewed
from also changes to match the different
panels of the comic page she is on
at one point scp-085 was introduced by
foundation personnel to a print copy of
ascending and descending
by the famous dutch artist m.c escher
this painting is of a large building
with its roof consisting of a looped
never-ending staircase when she
transferred onto the print of escher's
painting
scp-085 curiously explored her new
environment
and was able to ascend and descend the
staircase
the researcher gave cassie the name of
the piece and asked for her thoughts on
it
she remarked it's pretty i guess would
make a neat
exercise track when the researcher asked
if she noticed anything inconsistent
about the staircase
cassie replied no as far as i can tell
it just loops around
down up all the time why don't more
staircases do that
it's pretty neat following this cassie
directly requested more
impossible objects or optical illusions
to be drawn onto her page and made part
of her environment
unfortunately her request is still
pending review from the o5 council
being able to step from page to page
transferring herself onto canvas or
sheets of paper is but one of scp-085's
unique abilities
she can also interact with other drawn
objects on the same page she is on
if someone draws an item of clothing on
her page or a vehicle
even food or drink then cassie would be
able to wear
use or consume those objects drawn for
her behave as if they were real
but only when cassie is directly
interacting with them
the rest of the time they remain still
just as they were drawn
once scp-085 touches them these items
will animate
this same rule even applies to anything
drawn to depict something in motion
for example trees being blown in the
wind or the waves of an ocean
these will also stay perfectly still
when drawn and only move when acted upon
by scp-085
however much like her ability to
transfer from page to page
cassie's power over other
two-dimensional drawings has
limits drawing anything that would
normally be an inanimate object within
the real world will provide scp-085
something that she can directly interact
with
but this doesn't appear to be the case
for living beings
like another person or an animal that
would have its own autonomy and freedom
of movement in our three-dimensional
reality
animals and people drawn for cassie to
interact with will remain as static
unmoving drawings and will not become
animated like she is
even if drawn using scp-067
she cannot impart any of her own
sentience or free will onto these
drawings
and they remain still even when she
touches them
you might think that drawings of other
people whether they are animated or not
might help alleviate cassie's solitude
but if anything it just reminds her how
alone
she is scp foundation researchers have
noted that scp-085 is very friendly
towards them
and any subjects brought in to conduct
experiments with her visits from the
three-dimensional world
outside the page she inhabits seems to
offer some relief to cassie's loneliness
through much of her behavior she has
shown a fascination with our reality
and in particular she has an interest in
cars expressing that she wishes she had
an ability to work on them
this desire appears to be completely
genuine too
as shown when her photo was taken with
scp-978
the camera that reveals its subject's
inner desires
and in cassie's case showed her in a
fully realized 3d version of herself
working on a car scp-085's curiosity
about the world beyond the page is most
likely due to how different it is from
her everyday
two-dimensional existence but on at
least one occasion
cassie's curiosity got the better of her
and unintentionally led to a containment
breach
from the moment she was first drawn to
life and even after her initial testing
with researchers
scp-085 seemed unaware that she was a
two-dimensional being in a
three-dimensional world
foundation's security protocols
regarding scp-085 meant that no one on
the research team assigned to cassie was
permitted to tell her the truth about
her 2d nature
the truth about her existence was kept
from her with the best of intentions
as research staff did not want to cause
scp-085 any undue distress or trigger a
possible psychological snap
anything that cassie raised as an
inconsistency or discrepancy within her
world on the page
was explained by researchers to be the
result of her imagination or dreams
and research personnel attempted to
convince scp-085 that she was in a
scenario wherein she was the only human
survivor
searching for others in a
post-apocalyptic environment
however misguided this decision to
conceal the truth might have been
it was at least done with cassie's best
interests at heart
but a lie as they say is harder to
maintain than the truth
and keeping scp-085 in the dark about
her true nature
arguably led her to more hardship that
may have been avoided if she had been
allowed to know the truth
in the incident in question a foundation
researcher entered the room where the
drawing pad that cassie resides in was
found
and they were carrying a paper copy of
scp-085 special containment procedures
report
given that she had already partaken in
tests where she had transferred herself
to other paper and canvas surfaces
cassie assumed that this file was yet
another new environment for her to
explore
the researcher allowed scp-085 to make
direct contact with the report
and she was able to transfer over to the
document before the researcher realized
their mistake
whether this occurred accidentally or if
this researcher intended to confront
cassie with the truth about what she was
is unknown nevertheless cassie found
herself on the pages of her own
scp foundation file the record of every
test the research staff had conducted
a full description of how she had first
been drawn by scp-067 and brought to
life by scp-914
all clear as day in black and white
cassie's own true nature was presented
to her
immediately the yarns that foundation
researchers had spun about her surviving
an apocalypse began to unravel
was all a lie meant to keep her in the
dark and prevent her from ever knowing
that she was trapped in two dimensions
she returned to her original page
shortly later but the damage was already
done
due to her having breached containment
and briefly escaped into her own file
a number of foundation researchers
proposed that scp-085 be destroyed
there was always a risk of this
happening again what would happen if
cassie unwittingly found herself inside
another file
with access to more of the foundation's
sensitive information
however the o5 council decreed that
scp-085 was not to be terminated
allowing cassie to continue to exist
despite the breach
ever since she learned the truth about
herself signs of depression have begun
to manifest in her behavior
finding out you are a drawing trapped in
two dimensions with no chance of ever
having someone else for company
would be enough to crush anyone's spirit
but luckily researchers have since
managed to uplift cassie a little and
offer her a welcome distraction from her
unfortunate revelation the optical
illusions like the never-ending
staircase she requested were quickly
drawn into her environment
additionally given the interest she had
shown in the technical drawing of a 1964
ford mustang convertible
scp-085 had been allowed to assemble a
car of her own
by transferring each individual
component of the car from the blueprint
to her page
handron cassie had been gradually
building her very own mustang
to keep herself preoccupied from her
life in cartoon motion
and in the end if she can distract
herself and find that tiny bit of
happiness
isn't that all that matters in the sense
we're all trapped within our own
dimension
cassie and her 2d one us in our 3d world
filling our lives with hobbies and
entertainment all in an effort to make
sure that we never tug too hard at the
threads of our reality
and find out there just might be much
more out there
that we're missing now check out scp-999
the tickle monster
at scp-5094 miss j's whiz kids
schoolhouse
for more surprisingly wholesome
anomalies from the scp
foundation